ihn möchte mit ihnen dieses Gespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich. Wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Hanne Lore Lindemann.
Lindemann. Könnten Sie mir Ihren Namen und Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Ja, Hanne Lore schreibt sich H-A-Doppel-N-E-L-O-R-E.
Hanne Lore. Der Nachname Lindemann. L-I-N-D-E-M-A-N-N. Lindemann.
Lindemann. Ich möchte Ihren Namen wiederholen. Hanne Lore wie H-A-N-N-I-L-O-R-I. Hanne Lore.
Ja. Wie alt sind Sie?
Nein, Frau. Ich bin eine Frau. Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 1. Mai 1966.
Wie groß sind Sie? 1,60 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie? 68 Kilo.
68 Kilo. Und Frau Lindemann, können wir über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen? Was fühlt Sie sich heute?
Seit ungefähr drei Stunden habe ich ziemlich starke Schmerzen im linken Arm.
Das geht bis in die Finger. Bis in die Hand rein. Besonders am Daumen und am Zeigefinger strahlen die Schmerzen ein.
Daumen und Zeigefinger. Ja, ganz besonders. Einfach zu weit haben Sie Schmerzen auch.
Daumen und Zeigefinger. Ganz besonders. Aber es geht in die Hand rein. Besonders Daumen und Zeigefinger.
Seit drei Stunden, Frau Lindemann, haben Sie vorher ein Leben gefunden?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich angefangen? Ich verstehe. Oder? Langsam.
Innerhalb von einer Viertelstunde.
Eine Viertelstunde.
Und Frau Lindemann, wie ist der Schmerzcharakter?
Also es ist mehr so dumpf der Schmerz.
Es kribbelt auch etwas in den Fingern.
Und ich habe auch so ein ganz leichtes Taubheitsgefühl.
Taubheitsgefühl.
Stellen die Schmerzen irgendwo hin aus?
Zum Beispiel in den Nacken oder?
Also der Schmerz kommt so von hier habe ich den Eindruck so ein bisschen.
Aus der Schulternackenbereich und dann geht er in den Arm bis in die Hand.
Okay, Frau Lindemann.
Haben Sie gleichzeitig andere Beschwerden?
Zum Beispiel Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, Übelkeit und Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Ich habe irgendwie auch den Eindruck,
ich kann nicht mehr so richtig zugreifen.
Also normalerweise kann ich mit links immer gut zufassen.
Aber wenn ich jetzt eine Tasse hochheben möchte, die voll ist,
geht nicht gut. Ich habe weniger Kraft da drin.
Sind Sie sich verletzt?
Ich habe mich nicht verletzt, nein.
Aber keinen Unfall gehabt oder keinen Sturz.
Keinen Unfall, keinen Sturz.
Frau Lindemann,
wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
10 ist das stärkste.
Ja, wobei 0 ist nichts, 10 ist unerfältig Schmerzen sind.
Ich würde sagen 5 bis 6.
5 bis 6, ja.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Dann würde ich sagen, 5 bis 6.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Kribben und Taubheitsgefühl hatten.
Diese Beschwerden sind immer da oder wie ein Attacker?
Die sind immer da.
Seit 3 Stunden haben Sie Schmerzen.
Aber in Laufe der Zeit haben Sie Schmerzen.
Das ist ein Schmerz.
Seit 3 Stunden haben Sie Schmerzen.
Aber hat sich die Schmerzen in der Zeit verändert?
Oder immer gleich?
Sie sind innerhalb von 1 Viertelstunde
so stark geworden wie jetzt.
Wenn ich z.B. huste oder niesen muss
oder den Kopf drehe, nach links,
dann wird der Schmerz stärker.
Dann wird der Schmerz stärker.
Diese Sache verschlechtert die Schmerzen.
Aber gibt es etwas,
das die Schmerzen lindern kann?
Wenn ich mich ganz ruhig bewegen,
wenn ich nicht lache,
wenn ich nicht huste,
dann ist es vielleicht etwas besser.
Aber die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Ich verstehe.
Frau Lindemann, wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Gut.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, normalerweise schlafe ich gut.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Zugang?
Nein.
Ich hatte im letzten Jahr eine Darm-Spiegelung.
Eine Vorsorge-Darm-Spiegelung.
Das war in Ordnung.
Ich habe 3 Kinder, 3 Geburten.
Wenn die Blase voll ist
und ich lache oder huste,
dann geht manchmal etwas Urin ab.
Okay.
Das ist ein Niesen.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass bei Ihnen
eine Darm-Spiegelung durchgeführt wurde.
Warum?
Vorsorge.
Welche Beschwerden hatten Sie?
Keine.
Einfach Vorsorge.
Wir können in Deutschland Vorsorge-Darmspiegelungen machen.
Das kann man machen.
Einfach für Kontrolle?
Ja.
Haben Sie eine chronische Erkrankung?
Blut, Zucker oder?
Seit 5 Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
Seit 5 Jahren.
Seit 4 Jahren habe ich Zucker.
4 Jahre Zucker.
Andere?
Vor einem Jahr musste bei mir
ein Herz-Katheter gemacht werden.
Da wurden in die Herz-Kranz-Gefäße
2 Plastikröhrchen eingelegt.
Weil ich manchmal
ein enger Gefühl auf der Brust hatte.
Da hat man gesagt,
das Herz ist nicht gut durchblutet.
Danach ist es besser geworden.
Sie haben 2 Stand.
Ich glaube, Stand heißt das.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in der Brust?
Nein.
Keine Schmerzen in der Brust?
Oder ein enger Gefühl?
Nein.
Das ist gut.
Ich wollte fragen,
ob Sie noch eine Ältere beschwerden.
Nein, das ist anders.
Das ist anders.
Und dann?
Herz-Kranz-Gefäße durchgeführt.
2 Stand, Hochblutdruck und Zuckerkrankheit.
Irgendwas?
Nein.
Ich habe seit 4 Jahren
erhöhte Cholesterämöte.
Das war alles?
Ja.
Wurde bei Ihnen operiert?
Im Alter von 10 Jahren.
Da war ich noch ein Kind.
Da wurde der Blindarm operiert.
Vor 5 Jahren wurde die Gallenblase entfernt.
Ich hatte da Gallensteine und 2-mal Gallenkohlig.
2-mal?
Okay.
Andere Operation?
Nein, sonst nicht.
War die Operation komplikationlos?
Ja.
Ich möchte wiederholen.
Sie haben seit 3 Stunden
im linken Arm
Schmerzen
bis zum Zeigefinger
und zum Daumenfinger.
Aber in der letzten 4. Stunde
hat sich die Schmerzen
verschlechtert.
Deswegen sind Sie hier gekommen.
Die Schmerzcharakter Dumpf
Sie haben auch Kribben und Taubergefühl.
Gleichzeitig.
Auch die Schmerzen.
Sie denken,
dass die Schmerzen aus dem Nacken kommen.
Vielleicht.
Schmerzintensität liegt
5 von 10.
Die Schmerzen sind in den Naseen.
Und beim Kopfdrehen.
Okay.
Der Schmerz
ist aber nicht in der letzten Viertelstunde
stärker geworden.
Er hat langsam angefangen
und hat ungefähr 1 Viertelstunde benötigt.
Er ist seit dieser Zeit
seit 3 Stunden.
Er ist zuletzt gleichgeblieben.
Es hat sich nicht verschlechtert.
Okay.
Danke für Ihre Hinzufügen.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
1-2 Glas Wein pro Woche.
Was konsumieren Sie?
Substanzen?
Das ist eine Routinefrage
für die Anamnesgespräche.
Dann konsumieren Sie Noxen?
Drogen?
Nein.
Frau Lindemann.
Wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Das ist schon 2 Jahre her.
Das heißt, Sie sind in den Wechseln.
Ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Haben Sie Kinder?
3.
Sind Sie erwachsen?
Ja, über 30 Jahre.
Sie sind gesund.
Sie leben aber nicht mehr bei uns.
Jede Vogel fliegt andere.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Nein.
Mein Vater ist
im Alter von 68 Jahren
verstorben an einem Herzinfarkt.
Die Mutter
ist 86 Jahre alt.
Sie hat ein schwaches Herz.
Herzmuskelschwäche.
Sie hat auch eine Nierenschwäche.
Sie muss immer kontrolliert werden.
Eventuell muss sie
an eine Dialyse,
aber im Augenblick noch nicht.
Sie hat schlechte Nierenfunktion.
Ist Ihre Mutter
die Dialyse fliegt?
Noch nicht.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Mit meinem Mann.
Ist er gesund?
Ja.
Sind Sie in der letzten Zeit
in anderem Land gegangen?
Ja.
Ich war mal
für eine Woche in Frankreich.
Das war im Oktober.
Im März
war ich eine Woche in Italien.
Alles war in Ordnung.
Gab es irgendwelche Probleme?
Ich wollte eine Frage stellen
und Sie haben auch Beschwerden.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit
Ihren Körper überlastet?
Weiß ich nicht.
Heute habe ich mich angestrengt.
Da habe ich Gardinen aufgehängt.
Da musste ich auf eine Leiter steigen.
Ich musste einige Zeit die Arme hochheben.
Da musste ich immer
in den Nacken tun.
Danach traten diese Beschwerden auf.
Beim Haus?
Ja.
Gardine.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Erzieherin
in einer Kindertagesstätte.
Frau Lindemann
hat aufgrund ihrer Beschwerden
einen Verdacht auf
Halswirbel.
Ich wollte erklären
was das bedeutet.
Das ist Muskelverspannung.
Meistens ist es Muskelverspannung
im Nackenbereich.
Zuerst möchte ich
Sie körperlich untersuchen
und EKG schreiben.
EKG ist
eine Schmerzlosuntersuchung.
Das kenne ich.
Sehr gut.
Dann werde ich einige Tests
bestimmen.
Zum Beispiel in Labor.
Dann möchte ich Sie
eine Magnetresonanz-Tomographie
durchführen.
Das ist ein
bildgebender Verfahren.
Kennen Sie dieses Verfahren?
Ich habe davon gehört.
Das ist schmerzlos
und kristallenfrei.
Bei diesem Verfahren
können wir
die Gewebe von Körper
ausführlich beurteilen.
Das dauert 15 Minuten.
Das können wir so machen.
Danke.
Dann haben Sie Zeit sich vorzubereiten.
Ich habe keine Fragen mehr.
Ich habe keine Zusatzinformationen.
Die Kollegen
können jetzt
Fragen stellen.
Sie können sich konzentrieren
auf Ihre Übersetzung
der Patientensprache in Fachsprache.
Wir haben noch 2 Sachen,
die ich noch fragen würde.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ist bei Ihnen Allergien
und Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein.
Ich denke,
diese Punkte sind vergessen.
Leider.
Es sind mindestens 2 Punkte vergessen.
Aber sonst haben Sie das gut gemacht.
Was würden Sie noch fragen?
Hallo?
Ich möchte eine Frage stellen.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Eine ganz wichtige Frage.
Medikamenten, Anamnese.
Gegen Bluthochdruck,
Zuckerkrankheit und Höhe.
Ich nehme ein.
Für den Blutdruck
nehme ich ein Bisopolol.
5 steht dahinter.
2 am Tag.
1 morgens und 1 abends.
Kandisatan 8.
Und ASS 100.
1 Tablette morgens.
Und dann nehme ich noch für den Zucker
auch etwas ein.
Das heißt Metformin.
Da bin ich mir nicht mehr genau entklaren,
welche Stärke.
Aber ich meine, da steht etwas mit 800.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
800, dann nehme ich morgens 1 und abends 1 halbe.
Warum nehmen Sie ASS?
Ich habe mir gesagt, wegen dem Herzkatheter.
Wegen den Schläuchen im Herbst.
Wegen diesen Stents.
Und dann nehme ich noch ein.
Das heißt für das Cholesterin Rosuvastatin.
10 steht dahinter.
1 morgens und 1 abends.
Wichtig ist die Medikamenten, Anamnese.
Manchmal vergisst man sie.
Am besten ist es gleich zu fragen,
wenn jemand sagt, ich habe hohen Blutdruck seit 5 Jahren.
Dann kann man gleich sagen,
nehmen Sie Medikamente, dann vergessen Sie das nicht.
Ich wollte alles strukturieren, aber ich strukturiere.
Aber ich vergesse.
Was fehlt eventuell noch?
Medikamente waren schon wichtig.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Steigst du in die Schmerzen, wenn sie ins Bett liegen?
Nein.
Ich habe mich in den letzten 3 Stunden nicht ins Bett gelegt.
Das ist seit 3 Stunden der Schmerz.
Ich möchte mich gar nicht groß bewegen.
Weil das dann schlimmer wird.
Ich habe nur gesessen.
Nur gesessen?
Ja.
Das ist wichtig bei einem Unfallereignis.
Wichtig ist zum Gewichtsverhalten.
Haben Sie Ihr Gewicht verändert?
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht verändert?
Die Frage sollte gestellt werden.
Das Gewicht ist konstant geblieben.
Da ist nichts Auffälliges.
Die wesentlichen Fragen sonst sind gestellt worden.
Das ist alles gut.
Gibt es sonst noch Fragen, die Sie gestellt hätten?
Die wichtig erscheinen?
Man muss keine ausführliche Reiseanamnese machen.
Der Patient hat keinen Fieber, keinen Durchfall, keine Diarrhoe.
Da ist eine Reiseanamnese vielleicht nicht so entscheidend.
Es ist auch ein relativ akutes Schmerzereignis.
Das hatte die Patientin vorher noch nie.
Das ist ein sehr akutes Schmerzereignis.
Das hat die Patientin vorher noch nie.
Das ist etwas Neues.
Wenn keine weiteren Fragen sind,
haben Sie einige Minuten Zeit.
Ich lasse Sie in Ruhe, dass Sie sich konzentrieren können.
Ich komme gleich wieder.
Bis gleich.
Jetzt können Sie mich hören?
Ja.
Ich habe heute eine Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen diese Patienten vorstellen.
Es handelt sich um Frau Hanylore Lindemann.
Sie ist 59 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 1,60 m groß.
1,60 Meter groß und 68 Kilogramm.
Die Patienten stellten sich mit seit drei Stunden bestehenden Schmerzen im linken Arm vor.
Die Schmerzen, die beim Aufhängen von Gardinen begonnen haben und in den Daumen und Seigefinger ausstrahlen.
Sie können sagen, die Patientin stellte sich wegen seit drei Stunden bestehender Schmerzen im linken Arm vor.
Diese Schmerzen strahlen bis in die Finger D1 und D2 aus.
D1, D2 kann man sagen.
Der erste Finger ist weiß.
Das ist der erste Finger und der zweite Finger.
D1, D2 aus.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen seien eventuell nach dem Aufhängen von Gardinen, also eine ungewohnte Überkopfbelastung aufgetreten.
Fahren Sie bitte fort.
Wo beginnen die Schmerzen eventuell und was sind für Begleitsymptome dabei?
Sie haben gefragt, was haben Sie gesagt?
Ich habe es nicht richtig verstanden.
Sie haben gesagt, im linken Arm.
Sind die Schmerzen auch im Nacken oder in der Schulter oder wo sind die Schmerzen noch?
Die Patientin gab an, dass die Schmerzen in den linken Arm und in der linken Arm.
Aber die Patienten erwähnten, dass die Schmerzen aus dem Nacken kommen.
Die Patientin klagt über eine Zervikobrachialgie.
Ausstrahlend besonders in die Finger D1 und D2.
Dann haben wir den topografischen Bezug.
Halswirbelsäule, Arm, Zervikobrachialgie.
Was hat sie für Begleitsymptome?
Als Begleitsymptome habe ich die Patienten Kribbel und Taubergefühl an den Händen.
Ja, in dem Bereich.
Man kann sagen Kribbelparasthesien.
Kribbelparasthesien in dem beschriebenen Bereich.
Was hat die Patientin noch?
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass der Schmerzcharakter dunft ist.
Die Patientin kann nicht alles anfassen als sonst.
Sie können das umschreiben.
Es besteht eine gewisse Kraftminderung.
Die Patientin berichtet über eine Kraftminderung.
Mehr würde ich noch nicht sagen.
Sie können noch nicht diese Kraftminderung objektivieren.
Es gibt die Kraft gerade 1-5.
Dann kann man das einteilen.
Aber sie berichtet, dass sie eine gewisse Kraftminderung hat.
Was löst den Schmerz aus?
Was verstärkt den Schmerz?
Als Verstärkung sind Husten, Niesen.
Als Verlinderung ist es einfach im Durchbleiben.
Die Patientin hat noch einen Verschlimmerungsfaktor gesagt.
Husten, Niesen, Kopf, Drehchen.
Rotation.
Rotation der HWS verstärkt.
Wir könnten fragen, verstärkt das nach links?
Bei der Rotation nach links, zur Seite hin oder nach rechts?
Aber erst mal Kopf, Drehung, Rotation verstärkt ebenfalls.
Prima.
Berichten Sie bitte weiter.
In der Vergangenheit gibt es keinen bestimmten Unfall und keine Verletzung.
Die Patientin hat keine Schlafstörungen.
Die Anamnese ist unaufällig.
Die Patientin leidet an Hochblutdruck.
Erhöhte Hyperkolostronomie, Arteriehypertonie, Diabetes mellitus, Zip 2.
Auch wurde der Patient eine Angiographie durchgeführt.
Damit er zwei Stände bekommen hat.
Wann war das?
Vor zwei Jahren.
Sagen Sie ruhig, es besteht neben einer arteriellen Hypertonie seit fünf Jahren,
Diabetes mellitus seit vier Jahren, Hyperkolostereinämie seit vier Jahren,
besteht seit zwei Jahren eine coronare Herzerkrankung.
Eine k-h-k.
Deswegen wurde vor zwei Jahren bei einer Coronarengiographie ein Zweifachständ gelegt.
Aber die Diagnose bitte auch benennen.
Man kann einen Ständ nicht in der Herzkranzgefäße legen.
Was nehmen die Patienten für Medikamente?
Die Patienten nehmen regelmäßig Bisopolol, Candesatan und Acetylsäure.
Acetylsalicyl.
Aber Sie können ruhig sagen, ASS.
Können Sie mir die Dosierung denn sagen?
Welche Stärke? Bisopolol und Candesatan?
Candesatan acht. Bisopolol fünf.
Und wie viele Tabletten davon?
Beide sind eine Tablette.
Eine morgens, eine abends.
Candesatan zweimal, Bisopolol einmal.
Bisopolol auch zweimal.
Und nehmen Sie auch ein Antidiabetikum?
Ja, Sie nehmen Metformin ein.
Aber Sie erinnern nicht daran, welche Dosierung Sie nehmen.
Sie können sagen, Sie nehmen auch Metformin ein.
Die genaue Dosierung ist zurzeit nicht bekannt.
Das werden wir abklären.
Sie sind zurzeit nicht bekannt.
Ruhig da offen sein, haben wir noch nicht klären können in der kurzen Zeit.
Und nehmen Sie noch etwas gegen die Cholesterin ein?
Ja, Sopratestatin 20 mg.
Okay, gut. Eine am Tag, wahrscheinlich.
Gibt es Operationen in der Vorgeschichte?
Ja, bei der Patientin wurde Darmspiegelung durchgeführt.
Einfach für die Vorsorge.
Darmspiegelung ist eigentlich keine Operation.
Ja, Koloskopie.
Aber ich frage Sie nach Operationen.
Ist die Patientin schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, der Patient wurde operiert.
Hier, Entschuldigung.
Als sie 10 Jahre alt war, wurde bei ihr eine Belindertam-Operation durchgeführt.
Apendektomie.
Vor 5 Jahren.
Vor 5 Jahren wurde eine Kolististektomie durchgeführt.
Okay, gut.
Ja, prima.
Die Koloskopie vor 2 Jahren war in dem Sinne keine Operation.
Es war ein endoskopischer Eingriff, aber nicht unbedingt eine Operation.
Wenn dabei etwas gemacht worden wäre, ein großer Polyp entfernt wäre,
dann hätte man vielleicht gesagt, eine Koloskopie mit Polypektomie.
Aber ich würde sagen, erst mal die Operation war die Apendektomie im Kindesalter.
Mit 10 Jahren und die Kolististektomie vor 5 Jahren.
Okay, gut.
Können Sie mir etwas zur Familienvorgeschichte sagen?
Ja, die Patient von dem.
Entschuldigung.
Die Patient, die Familiengeschichte, ja, meinen Sie es so richtig.
Ich dachte über ihren Mann, la la la.
Okay, die Patient, die in der Familienanamnese gibt es einen Herzinfarkt beim Vater.
Und deshalb ist er an Herzinfarkt verstorben mit 68 Jahren.
Sagen Sie bitte Myokartinfarkt.
Ah, Myokartinfarkt, ja.
Sagen Sie es ganz kurz in einem Satz.
Sagen Sie ruhig, der Vater ist im Alter von 68 Jahren an einem Myokartinfarkt verstorben.
Ja, das reicht.
Und die Mutter, was ist mit der Mutter?
Die Mutter ist 86 Jahre alt.
Sie lebt und sie leitet an Herzinsuffizienz und Nearenversagen.
Aber jetzt eventuell bekommt sie keine Dialysis.
Aber die Ärzte sprechen darüber.
Ja, also Nearenversagen würde ich vielleicht noch nicht sagen.
Sie hat eine Herzinsuffizienz, eine Myokartinsuffizienz und eine Neareninsuffizienz.
Das würde ich erst mal so machen. Mehr würde ich im Augenblick gar nicht sagen.
Gut, Geschwister, hat die Patientin Geschwister?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Das stimmt, das hat sie nicht gefragt. Aber sie hat keine Geschwister.
Gut, okay. Ja, jetzt würde mich interessieren, was hat die Patientin?
Was ist die Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, aufgrund von einer Mnistischenangabe habe ich einen Verdacht auf die Halswebelsäule-Zentrum.
Ja, okay.
Das ist eine Verdachtsdiagnose. Um die Diagnose zu bestätigen, muss ich einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zum Beispiel MRE.
Aber erst mal machen Sie eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Im Labor würde ich gerne Blut abnehmen und dann röntgen.
Röntgen für die zwei Ebenen, für die Nacken und Schulter.
Wahrscheinlich wird es so sein, dass Sie schon vielleicht aufgrund der körperlichen Untersuchung feststellen,
dass die Patientin nicht nur ein HWS-Syndrom hat, was ja ganz viele Menschen haben.
Diese Diagnose ist so eine umfassende Diagnose. HWS-Syndrom.
Das sind alle Beschwerden, die von der Halswebelsäule kommen.
Aber die Patientin hat ja auch neurologische Symptome.
Die Patientin hat Kribbelparastasie. Die Patientin hat eine Kraftminderung.
Die Patientin hat ausstrahlende Beschwerden in das Segment D1, D2.
Das würde ja bestimmten Halswirbelsäulensegmenten zugeordnet sein.
Sie hat eine Verstärkung beim Husten und Niesen.
Und bei der Kopfrotation. Das spricht schon für meine Begriffe fast für einen Diskusprolaps oder für eine Radikulopathie.
Also wahrscheinlich eine Zervikobrachialgie. C5, C6 wahrscheinlich.
Und eventuell mit Diskusprolaps.
Eigentlich sozusagen wegen der Begleitssymptome wollte ich direkt eine MRI durchführen.
Deswegen habe ich so gesagt. MRI.
Gut, das wäre die weiterführende, exakte Diagnose wahrscheinlich.
Aber die klinische Symptomatik spricht schon dafür.
Differentialdiagnostik. Was kommt denn dazu?
Als Differentialdiagnostik. Migrant Attacker. Vielleicht Migrant Attacker.
Denken Sie daran, die Patientin hat eine coronare Herzerkrankung.
Ja, akute coronare Sendung.
Kann sein. Zumindest muss man es ausschließen.
Oder kann man sozusagen. Ja, das ist genug.
Also es reicht eigentlich, wenn Sie eine Verdacht...
Metastas kann man sagen.
Eine Differentialdiagnose.
Aufgrund der kardialen Vorgeschichte der Patientin würde ich da vielleicht ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein.
Und würde die Anamnese unterbrechen.
Sicherheitshalber bei der Patientin. Auch wenn die Beschwerden nicht so ganz typisch sind.
Aber sie hat eine KHK und vor zwei Jahren eine Stentum gekriegt.
Sie hat eine positive Familienanamnese.
Ich würde vielleicht kurz die Anamnese unterbrechen.
Ich würde den Blutdruck messen. Ich würde SBO2 messen und ein EKG ableiten.
Das würde ich zumindest mal ganz kurz machen.
Es macht einen guten Eindruck für den Prüfer in der Prüfung.
In diesem Fall auch. Ja, würde ich ruhig machen.
Weil es ist ja nicht ganz klar. Klinisch ist das eine Zervikobrachialgie. Klinisch. Eindeutig.
Was ist der Auslöser über Kopftätigkeit, leckere Zeit, Nacken?
Und dann beginnt es der Hustenschmerz, Niesenschmerz, Rotationsschmerz, Kribbelparistisin.
Aber wie gesagt, die Neurologie ist ja da.
Und das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur ein HWS-Syndrom.
Was manchen würde haben mit reiner Muskelverspannung.
Sondern da ist eine Neurologie hinter. Da wäre ich vorsichtig.
Und sie hat eine positive kardiale Anamnese.
Da würde ich sicherheitshalber einfach mal sagen, ich unterbreche kurz.
Ich messe ihren Blutdruck. Ich messe ihren Sauerstoffgehalt.
Und ich nehme zumindest an, ein Kanal EKG mal ab.
Das beruhigt Sie als Arzt oder das beruhigt die Patientin?
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Das beruhigt. Ja, es beruhigt.
Sie und Sie sagen, okay, ich habe mich da jetzt abgesichert erst mal.
Und die Patientin hat den Eindruck, oh, der Doktor ist empathisch.
Der kümmert sich um mich.
Es dauert ja nicht lange. Diese Unterbrechung dauert nicht lange.
Ja, stimmt. Ich habe eine Frage.
Was ist die Discus Prolaps oder was ist die Hasbebel-Säule auch Discus Prolapses um?
Ja, man kann sagen, es ist Verdacht auf Discus Prolaps.
Oder man kann sagen, Verdacht auf Zervicobrachialgie.
Zervicobrachialgie, meinetwegen C5D6, im Sinne einer Wurzelreizung, einer Radikulopathie.
Das kann man ruhig sagen.
Damit haben Sie das Neurologische auch betont, was ja ohne Zweifel vorliegt bei der Patientin.
Ja.
Ein reines Halswirbelsäulen-Syndrom macht selten Kribbelparastisin in bestimmte Finger.
Wenn ein Patient kommt und sagt, es kribbelt mir überall im Arm,
dann ist das die neurologische Zuordnung schwierig.
Aber wie kann man diese Krankheit Patienten erklären? Sie haben das, das, das?
Ich würde noch nicht gleich sofort dem Patienten eine Diagnose sagen.
Wenn der Patient sagt, was habe ich denn, was kann das denn sein, dann würde ich vorsichtig sein.
Ich würde sagen, ich glaube, Sie haben ein Problem, was aus der Halswirbelsäule kommt.
Wie sieht das so schildern auch?
Halswirbelsäule umgangssprachlich?
Ja, aus der Patientensprache.
Sie dürfen jetzt gegenüber der Patientin nicht sagen, Sie haben eine Radikulopathie.
Das versteht die Patientin nicht.
Sagen Sie ruhig, das Problem kommt vielleicht aus der Halswirbelsäule.
Aber wir müssen noch mehrere Schritte machen, um das genau festzustellen.
Und dafür brauche ich eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Und je nach körperlicher Untersuchung werden wir noch mehr.
Bei einer körperlichen Untersuchung werden wir gegebenenfalls bildgebende Verfahren machen,
wie Röntgen oder wie ein MRT, so etwas.
Das kann man dann erweitern.
Aber immer erst etwas offen lassen, nicht gleich eine Diagnose nennen.
Da wäre ich vorsichtig.
Sagen Sie ruhig, ich glaube, es hängt mit Ihrer Halswirbelsäule zusammen.
Und das müssen wir jetzt noch näher abklären.
Wenn Sie aber auch mir berichtet haben, dass Sie einen Herzkatheter gehabt haben und zwei Stents haben,
müssen wir uns auch um Ihr Herz kümmern.
So, ja.
Also ich würde etwas offen lassen.
Noch nicht zu früh festlegen, weil das kann manchmal gefährlich sein.
Weil man ist dann so etwas, wir nennen das wie in einem Tunnel.
Und Sie sehen nur in dem Tunnel, das ist das.
Und rechts und links sehen Sie dann nichts mehr.
Das kann gefährlich werden.
Ja, bei diesem Fall mache ich es so.
Ich würde immer ein bisschen das offen lassen, wenn die Patienten auch fragen, was kann das sein?
Sowas habe ich ja noch nie gehabt.
Sagen Sie nicht gleich, Sie haben einen Bandscheibenvorfall.
Das fände ich etwas sehr riskant.
Seien Sie ruhig, es kann mit Ihrer Halswirbelsäule zu tun haben.
Das ist so meine erste Vermutung.
Aber ich muss Sie jetzt noch untersuchen.
Und dann weiß ich immer einen Schritt mehr.
Da weiß ich genaueres, habe ich mehr Informationen.
Und gegebenenfalls müssen wir dann einen Röntgen machen oder einen MRT.
Kurz erklären vielleicht, was ein MRT ist.
Viele wissen das inzwischen ja auch viele Patienten.
Aber etwas offen lassen.
Und dann suchen lassen.
Ist besser, glaube ich.
Vielen Dank.
Ja, erstmal vielen Dank.
Machen Sie bald Prüfung?
Ja, ich habe eine Prüfung, 7. Mai.
Ja, ist ja bald.